au sommaire la cascade biberon à la
plaine des palmistes la curiosité de la
semaine le pavillon des abeilles au
domaine des tourelles
rendez-vous à la plaine des palmistes
après avoir dépassé la mairie en venant
de l'est tourner à droite en direction
de la cascade biberon après avoir longé
le rempart vous pouvez vous garer au
départ du sentier
pour cette randonnée très facile de 1 km
en aller retour prévoir de quoi vous
protéger de la pluie et une réserve
d'eau
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
la cascade biberon qui coule toute
l'année est l'une des plus belles de la
réunion on s'y rend à moindre effort par
un sentier très bien aménagé fréquenté
tant par les touristes que par les
locaux
si la cascade constitue un très joli but
de balade le sentier en lui-même est
moins intéressant d'un point de vue
écologique notamment parce qu'une bonne
partie est envahi par du goyavier très
présent dans cette région de l'île on
arrive dans un milieu complètement
envahi alors qu'on nous parle de tes
plantes exotiques envahissantes là on a
un exemple assez flagrant voilà en un
milieu où les goyaviers sont tellement
serré que quand on regarde au pied on a
plus de
tipiak bois pays quéro poussins c'est
impossible de pousser tellement le
milieu très serré et même nous si on
veut se balader là-dedans sa peau si
vous voyez difficilement 2 est difficile
de pénétrer dans des forêts comme ça
sans avoir à pénétrer dans ces fours et
danse on peut tout de même parfois il
trouver de jolies choses
alors là on aime tiny alors qu'ils
pourraient être bien celui du d'oiseaux
la vierge là je me suis permis de
toucher parce que je sais que la période
de reproduction des oiseaux entre autres
et est largement passée et puis on
voyait que mon le nid quand même très
très ancien il ya eu des insertions de
mousse
que l'onil et n'est plus plus habiter
apparemment depuis quelques temps déjà
malgré cette omniprésence de plantes
exotiques parfois belles à regarder
c'est bien ce spécimen de bois de pâte
haïti qui est observable en bord de
sentiers
ça
à mesure que l'on s'approche de la
cascade biberon le bruit des chutes
d'eau est de plus en plus présent une
fois arrivé à son pied on prend la
mesure de son impressionnante auteurs
une colonne d'eau de 250 m alimenté par
la forêt de l'île et de patience au
dessus qui fournit aussi en au grand
étang et la rivière des marsouins
un spectacle féerique comme la réunion
nous en offre si souvent
âgées
ce que j'aime beaucoup sur cette
randonnée c'est qu'il ya le côté
familial j'adore aussi quand on peut
faire des petites rangoun randonnée
faire découvrir des petits coins à toute
la famille l'ensemble de la famille de
sentiers et pas long il n'y a pas de
difficultés majeures comme on a pu voir
au tout début du sentier vraiment
c'est une piste vraiment
il ya du scories il n'y a pas de risque
de chute dans la dernière partie un
petit peu plus délicat mais pas de
grosses difficultés majeures à moins de
500 mètres de là d'une voie carrossable
avoir une cascade dans les eaux je pense
que c'est une des cascades de
effectivement les plus accessibles dans
l'est et dans les eaux sur ce que n'aime
pas sur cette randonnée d'ailleurs mme
yade récemment à tous les réunionnais
d'ailleurs pour reprendre un petit peu
la chanson à ses salines petit pays sans
habitants et amélie va la bouteille à
l'été plein et est plus lourde à porter
à l'aller que l'aller c'est carrément à
côté de la cascade vivront donc la chose
y avance mais encore un petit peu de
choses à faire encore pas tout les
négatifs heureusement on a encore des
choses à faire et ben on va constater
que de plus en plus de monde d'ailleurs
il marche avec nos petits sacs de
déchets c'est une bonne chose continue
et
miel cyr gelée royale les produits de la
ruche peuvent servir à de nombreux
usages le pavillon des abeilles au
domaine des tourelles et notre curiosité
de la semaine
le pavillon des abeilles c'est une
entreprise au travers de laquelle je
fais découvrir aux autres le monde des
abeilles de travail des apiculteurs à
travers des ateliers pédagogiques
je fais également des des ateliers de
fabrication de pain d'épicés de
biscuits de savon au miel de savon à la
propolis de bougies en cire d'abeille de
sujets en cire d'abeille voilà un petit
peu les produits que l'on peut
travailler au niveau de la ruche le miel
la sir le pollen la propolis et la gelée
royale j'ai eu la chance de venir en
vacances à la plaine quand j'étais petit
et les gens chez qui je venais à la
plaine avait des abeilles donc c'est
quelque chose qui va là qui m'a plu j'ai
l'impression à chaque fois que j'ouvre
une ruche d'apprendre d'apprendre encore
encore encore encore et que j'ai
l'impression d'être vraiment tout tout
tout petit côté par rapport à ce
qu'elles ont à m'apprendre chacun est à
sa place chacun travaille et chacun
travaille en plus dans le but de la
communauté je crois que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse le plus ce que c'est ça
cette cette notion de solidarité enfin
voilà cette notion de kia qui ça
m'interpelle